sí
en el vídeo anterior probablemente notas
de que un agujero muy pequeño da como
resultado una imagen más nítida pero es
una imagen muy tenue porque muy pocos
rayos de luz logran pasar por la
apertura y entrar en la cámara podemos
aumentar el brillo de la imagen
agrandando el tamaño de la apertura pero
hay un problema cuando lo hacemos la
imagen se vuelve borrosa esta es la
razón
veamos la escena de nuevo y un punto
específico de la escena la luz rebota
por toda la escena y los rayos de luz de
este punto van en todas direcciones la
apertura sólo deja pasar la luz de una
dirección si lo agrandamos dejará pasar
más rayos de luz y la imagen se volverá
más brillante pero esto presenta un
nuevo problema deja que la luz de
nuestro punto se disperse por todo el
plano de la imagen ese puntito de
nuestra escena cubre una gran área de
nuestra imagen es una imagen borrosa
aparte del tamaño de nuestra apertura
hay otra característica importante de
esta cámara que podemos manipular es la
distancia entre el plano de la imagen y
la p
llamaré a esta distancia distancia focal
si movemos el plano de la imagen más
cerca de la apertura los objetos de la
escena aparecen más pequeños pero vemos
más detalles de la escena decimos que
nuestro campo de visión se amplifica
cuando lo hacemos y si movemos el plano
de la imagen más lejos de la apertura
ocurre lo contrario ahora los objetos de
la escena aparecen más grandes pero
captamos menos elementos de la escena
en este caso decimos que el campo de
visión es cerrado
hay una especie de relación entre la
distancia focal de la cámara y el campo
de visión es un concepto muy importante
hagamos una pausa en el próximo
ejercicio tendrás oportunidad de
desarrollar tu comprensión de lo que
ocurre jugando con una cámara
estenopeica virtual con una distancia
variable entre la apertura y el plano de
la imagen
inténtalo